c'est tout simplement du jamais vu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
les naissances en 2020 en france sont au
plus bas depuis 1945
et selon l'insee on parle d'une chute de
13% et naissance en janvier 2021 par
rapport à l'année précédente mais en
réalité cela fait six ans que la
natalité chute
tous les ans en france alors cette
baisse est elle vraiment historique
le colis de 19 ans n'est-il l'unique
responsable et la natalité chute elle
chaque fois que la france traverse une
crise
on essaye d'y voir plus clair dans
facture on a pu présenter un moment
attention au kobus 19 octobre il
19 et il se trouve que les faits en
réalité a été plutôt inverse cet effet
gros bide 19 dont ce médecin nous parle
beaucoup y croyait dès le début de
l'épidémie il s'attendait à ce que le
colis 19h15 baby boom
certains avaient annoncé un baby-boom
confiné isolés privés de sorties et de
loisirs
les français en couple s'occuperait
comme ils le peuvent en faisant des
bébés pourtant c'est exactement inverse
qui s'est produit en 2020 7 135 mille
bébés sont venus au monde en france soit
à peu près 18 mille de moins que l'année
précédente en 2019 il s'agit du plus
faible nombre annuel de naissance en
france depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
inférieurs même au point le plus bas
observé en 94 les bébés nés en décembre
2020 en janvier 2021 ont donc été conçus
logiquement aux alentours de mars et
avril 2000 en soit le début du premier
confinement à première vue il paraît
donc logique que le colis de 19,6 soit
un petit peu pour quelque chose
puis évidemment l'impact direct lié à la
crainte du virus à la fois le fait que
ce virus puisse impacter plus lourdement
les gens dansent un tiers monde sait que
le fait d'être enceinte est un facteur
de risque supplémentaire de forme pas
même si les femmes en salle j'ai
rarement son jeune puis donc il ya
l'impact potentiel sur le foetus qui
n'était pas très bien connu aimant la
plume est rassurante
ça fait partie des éléments qui ont pu
contribuer à ce que les couples s'engage
pas de fuite sur une nouvelle grossesse
pertes d'emplois hausse du chômage peur
de transmettre le virus mais aussi
isolement social et télétravail une
étude menée par trois démographie
italien au début du premier confirmant
auprès de jeunes européens confirment
que les crises créer un climat
d'incertitude qui déprime grandement les
projets familiaux et ça ça n'est pas
nouveau
alors pour mieux comprendre revenons un
peu en arrière et jetons un oeil à
quelques épisodes clés de l'histoire il
ya les périodes de guerre qui ont
entraîné la séparation des couples la
première guerre mondiale a été
accompagnée d'une chute de naissance de
moitié pendant quatre ans de guerre est
là clairement c'est des couples qui ont
été séparés et aussi des coupes qui
n'ont pas pu se former eu des mariages
qui devait avoir lieu qui ont été
reportés la seconde guerre mondiale a
été accompagnée d'une baisse des
naissances mais beaucoup moins
importante que la première guerre
mondiale parce que mais la proportion de
couples qui ont été séparées a été plus
faible alors là je vous parle de période
de guerre là on n'est pas en guerre
évidemment comparer 2020 et 1945 fait
très peu de sens mais même sans parler
de guerre mondiale les naissances semble
surtout suivre le mouvement des
économies ce que nous confirme gilles
pison si on fait un bilan des crises
économiques survenues depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale on s'aperçoit
qu'une crise elle est souvent suivie
d'une baisse des naissances un ou deux
ans après en 1974 et 75 c la hausse
brutale du prix du pétrole qui fait
chuter le pib en france en 1976 quelques
mois plus tard les naissances atteignent
une baisse mensuelle qui dépasse celle
de 2020 avec -14%
mais aussi on était à la fin du
baby-boom et donc les naissances étaient
en baisse importante depuis un ou deux
ans donc la crise n'a fait qu'accentuer
une baisse qui était déjà là dans son
rapport l'insee fait référence à une
année en particulier 735 me les bébés
sont nés en 2020 ce qui est le point le
plus bas observé depuis 94 et en effet
cette date n'échappe pas à la règle
au début des années 90 une récession
mondiale fait chuter le pib de la france
en 93
puis s'ensuit en 94 une baisse des
naissances
plus récemment ce sont les effets de la
crise économique de 2008 qui ont
provoqué une légère baisse des
naissances partout en europe
à un détail près toutefois la natalité
française fut moins touchées en cause
les politiques sociales et familiales de
la france bien plus solide qui booste
généralement la confiance des ménages en
leur avenir
gallet mesures d'accompagnement chômage
partiel et cetera pour pallier pour
partie des conséquences de la crise
cette singularité française se reflète
également dans les naissances en plein
coït 19,6 en france nous regrettons
cette baisse de 7% en décembre
elle a pourtant atteint 20 % en italie
c'est pourquoi selon certains
démographes la crise ducobu 19 va faire
reculer la natalité en france de manière
beaucoup moins importante que chez ses
voisins européens
cette baisse en 2020 potentiellement
liés aux copies de 19 et surtout inédite
au sens que les couples ne se forme pas
car ils ne se rencontrent pas tout
simplement la fermeture des restaurants
cafés cinémas discothèques et le respect
de la distanciation physique
il faut aussi noter que la fermeture des
centres de pma pendant le confinement a
pu avoir de lourdes conséquences
en effet la procréation médicalement
assistée en france représentent 3 5% des
naissances
nous pouvons donc bel et bien parler
d'une baisse historique des naissances
en france mais il faut garder à l'esprit
deux points très importants
le premier c'est qu'il faudra surtout
surveiller les prochains mois de 2021
pour savoir si cette tendance se
confirme
ou pas enfin ces chiffres s'inscrivent
donc dans une baisse continue qui
remonte au début des années 2010 alors
que l'âge de la première grossesse ne
cesse de reculer depuis 50 ans en france
mais en observe aussi que souvent une
crise n'empêche pas les naissances
il reporte à plus tard à voir si comme
pour les crises économiques passé il y
aura récupération des naissances en
sortie de crise où notre pays je pense
que la qualité élevée cm à un marqueur
et puis un gage de vitalité pour
l'avenir